hello everyone welcome back to a brand
new episode of the witching hour
that haley i think i can speak for you
right now too
we're very excited about this interview
because we have the director of
the fear street movies with us and uh
i mean i'll just flat out say i'm
obsessed with 1994 which is all we're
talking about on this edition of the
witching hour so lee
huge congratulations to you it's
something else i seriously can't get
over it i might have watched the movie
more than once
that's so kind thank you
co-sign all of that it is wonderful and
i'm so excited to have an hour to pick
your brain about it
great take your brain about that and
more
because we wanted to start by going back
to what happened immediately after
honeymoon
came out one is the success of a movie
like that
something that opens more doors for you
and two if it does
how do you kind of take hold of all
those opportunities and really make
something with it because
a lot of directors hit the festival
circuit they come out with something
that's really really special and then
the momentum doesn't exactly build like
it has for you
totally it was i was very i think very
lucky in that
honeymoon was really embraced by the
festival community and then also the
horror community
um in a way that was amazing and kind of
like
exactly what i had hoped for to happen
with that movie
um and so right after the movie
like shortly thereafter i think i i
started getting more opportunities to
direct
television um right away which was huge
for me to be able to like get paid to
direct something
because i obviously got paid for
honeymoon but that was an indie so it
was it was small so i was like whoa this
is like a thing like i'm actually
might be able to make a career of this
um so i was lucky enough to direct a few
episodes of scream which was on mtv
at the time um and then i directed an
episode of this show called outcast
which robert kirkman
created for cinemax which was an amazing
opportunity
um and in the meantime my writing
partner phil and i were we were writing
our own stuff and we were also
lucky enough to get hired to write on
studio movies um
and somewhere in that like kind of
whirlwind of things
um i was attached to do the remake of
the craft which i love
um and then ultimately that didn't work
out schedule wise
um but right around that time
which is it's so crazy it's like when i
say this now i'm like holy [ __ ] i can't
believe it's been this long
but it was like 2017 that i had my first
conversations about fear street
um and so yeah it's been a long time
i have a tv follow-up question because
i do love the scream tv series and
outcast is quite good as well
are those two things situations where
you're able to
you know have something pitch to you and
say yes this speaks to what i want to do
or because i imagine at that point it's
difficult to say
no to something was there ever an
opportunity to direct maybe another show
that kind of didn't speak to your
sensibilities as much as i
think as a viewer those two shows did
yeah definitely i
you know there were other shows that i
kind of had gotten sent the scripts for
that i it just wasn't it wasn't
something like in my wheelhouse it was
maybe there were maybe opportunities
that like
were things that i would watch but as
far as like me
being the right person to direct it i
just didn't quite like connect like
there were some things that were like a
little more drama based
and and i will watch a lot of that but i
like to move the camera
and i like genre so it was like scream
and outcasts were
right in the sweet spot of those two
things so
yeah obviously it's like it's always a
bummer when a project doesn't come
together and
i would love to have seen your version
of the craft
but because this first installment 1994
plays so closely with the hallmarks of
that time period and horror
did you end up finding out that any of
the work you had put into that
turned out to be really useful coming on
to something that was
very mid-90s focused no you know the
only kind
because i feel like well okay so the
craft i think was also 96 which is when
scream came out
scream was definitely the touchstone for
for 94 the 94 versi
part of fear street um i would say that
the the main
the movies are so different kind of like
even tonally i would say that the main
thing is is weird but
i did do i was just like starting to do
like kind of preliminary
like costume like thinking when i was on
the craft
and so some of that some of that kind of
like
deep cut like outsider like grunge like
look with something that
like those like reference images i could
bring over like when i started working
through a street but other than that
they were kind of
totally different universes um so
not as much but a little i feel like i
might be crossing a line but are we
allowed to ask you anything about what
your
rendition of the craft was going to be
like is it anything like what we wound
up getting which
we're both big fans of but i imagine
your version
would have been a bit different you know
what it was like the difference
was when i was um when i was attached to
it it was at sony
and i can't remember i don't remember if
the new version
also was at sony but it the new version
became a blumhouse movie which was like
a smaller kind of budget
and so like the version that phil and i
were working on was just a different
movie it was bigger it was just like a
little bit bigger
um and and yeah so that that's what i
would say it was just like more of like
a
that's it i can kind of picture it or at
least i can picture something
but i do i really like the one that came
out and i love the original one so i was
kind of just
really happy i was just happy that they
made the movie
and you know what i mean like in the end
it was like i didn't think that like it
didn't work out schedule-wise for me but
i was just
very pumped that they still did it and i
like it so i'm happy about it
very much agree with that i dressed the
part today
i had to any opportunity to wear this
shirt i'm going to take it but speaking
of
my love for scream i'm kind of asking
you for the secret sauce here but
what is the key to borrowing something
from a classic or paying homage to a
classic
while still making sure it's not
it's not using it abusing something that
uh people loved before
but it also has your own spin on it
because this is one of the
i think this is one of the best balanced
you know way ways of doing that that
i've seen in a while because i'm very
sensitive to the way that scream
is is used and uh i think you do it
quite well here
thank you um i don't know that's a big
question the
scream for me is maybe
i mean i think it's one of the best
movies ever made period
like horror aside it's it's so brilliant
and it's
daunting it's daunting when you go back
and watch that movie and you're like i'm
gonna use this
amazing brilliant masterpiece as an
inspiration um
but one of the things that i really like
love about it obviously the filmmaking
is incredible the scares are incredible
um tonally i love that it sits in this
place where the characters are
self-aware
to a certain degree obviously it's
living in that like very like you know
self-referential like horror world
um which i just thought was brilliant
and with fear street i wanted to be able
to walk a line that was was doing the
things that you said that like paid
homage to it and everything but didn't
dip
too much into being parody um so i
wanted to like have nostalgia
in in all three you know kind of
installments of fear street but
but never but still try to do something
new um
so a lot of that just came from the
story and i think the fact that like
fear street isn't just 1994 but that we
had the space to kind of let these
characters expand
over the three generations let it become
more than just
you know just like a thing that was like
hello scream you're perfect you know
um and also the other thing about making
making a movie now
versus the mid 90s is that i think
audiences and
also um you know production companies
and studios
will allow you to tell a story with
protagonists that we didn't see as much
back then
so that was really cool and important to
fear street because fear street is a
story about
outsiders in a very different way than
like
the characters in scream so all of that
just like let it become
organic in a different way but still
kind of like
bow down at the altar of perfection that
is screen
you mentioned your sort of sprawling
narrative that you get to
play with in this really unique
structure and production approach he
took
was there and i know we're avoiding
spoilers for some of the
yeah the other generations but broadly
speaking was that one of them in
particular
sort of the the seed of the idea that
you grew from
uh how did you arrive at these specific
timelines
and which are you know that's out there
we know there's timelines
yeah yeah yeah no i mean honestly like
what we did was so i got hired
to direct the movies and to to write the
movies and
kind of be like the person the vision of
it
and um i had a small writer's room with
my writing partner
and kate treefry who wrote movie three
with me and then zac okowitz who worked
on movie two
and it was a small writer's room it was
only for like a couple like four weeks
five weeks something like that
and we really kind of tackled
the entire thing it was always like
we're telling this big sprawling story
and we had um peter chernin who is my
producer
had this idea of wanting to release kind
of like a trilogy
all in the same year that was his idea
that he kind of brought to the table and
he was brilliant and i think he was like
i don't know how we're going to do this
but
it's cool we should do it and the
challenge that
we had was okay but now it's more than
an
idea like how do we actually make these
something that
people would want to see in like a
close amount of time and also not feel
like they're just getting jerked around
because at the time when we were
developing
the movies were still theatrical so
this is a long-winded way of getting to
answer your question but but basically
we what we came up with was that we were
doing something
kind of new that is like this hybrid
between movies
and like between traditional television
content so
we wanted each movie to feel satisfying
and like
kind of complete in its own like
resolving of the main tension
and then also we wanted to make sure
that the narrative that was driving us
forward into the third movie
was staying compelling and like we were
still uncovering new things
and um and the idea of using the three
different time periods kind of grew out
of that and
i've always just been obsessed with this
idea of
you know history repeating itself and
like how like the wrongs of the past can
keep coming back until you write them
so it just became this kind of really
fun thing and then
as a horror fan i placed one of them in
the mid-90s because i felt like that was
like its own era of slasher
and then 70s was obviously the heyday
like that like that little kind of
border between late 70s and early 80s
um and then 1666 is obviously a whole
new whole new ballgame
going back to the interview that we did
a good while ago
at that time you told me that you were
more you considered yourself more a
sci-fi
fan than a horror fan and there were
some gaps in your knowledge
it sounds like that might have changed
to me
well i still think that like sci-fi is
like my like
main thing that i'm into i but i i
certainly grew
up like i don't know if we talked about
this in the initial interview because i
was a kid in the 80s
renting horror movies on vhs for slumber
parties was like
the pinnacle so i i would say that like
the thing that's intimidating to me
still is that especially when you're on
like the festival circuit
and you're like amidst like all of the
midnight movies everyone has seen
every tiny horror movie
that has ever been made that is still
not me
so i feel like i have a very good breath
of knowledge of like
mainstream like and not even just
mainstream but like when we start to get
like real deep cut
i'm like oh no that's like next level
i'm still not there i mean i have a lot
still to do there
but yeah it's understandable it makes me
look forward to one of our two questions
that we always end our episodes on but
i'm going to save that for later
all right good we're talking a little
bit about the the earlier days of
working on this and
you you said it was 2017 right yeah it
was 2017 that i got hired yeah
so did you get caught up in the fox
disney of it all and if so
what was it like watching all of that
happen around you
when the project i think was originally
meant to be distributed through 20th
century fox
oh yeah it was wild it was wild it was
it was really weird and
you know we kind of so so yes we were at
fox
and we i think we wrote
like the first drafts of the scripts and
then cut to
2018 and we were kind of in
what i would call like a soft prep like
we were we were inching closer to the
green light
and that's when things started to happen
like like at the studio at a level that
like i
kind of only understand still to this
day
but it became a very like kind of
complicated political situation as fox
was trying to like
figure out like what movies could they
make
how were they making movies what would
the merger mean we the merger hadn't
been like immortalized yet but we
knew it was coming um and we
when i say we like me and the producers
we were just like driving home like we
believe in these movies we've worked on
these movies
they should be made they need to be made
and we were just driving forward like
trying to get that green light
and um they they went away for a second
like there was a brief moment in 2018
where
things got a little like you know full
of turmoil i'd say and
and i didn't think they were gonna
happen i went and i shot a pilot and
then when i was shooting the pilot
i um i got a call from one of my
producer being like no no no no we're
back like this is gonna happen
and then um beginning of 2019 i was
prepping
for real and then we shot all of 2019
and then the merger actually happened
which was just crazy because it's like
oh you know i love a disney movie
like anyone else but like my god like
these are not disney movies
what does that mean and what does fox
mean and what like you know there was
like that fear of
these movies were always rated um
and that was important to me because i
feel like
like there's a lot of good pg-13 horror
movies but slasher movies need to be
rated r
and um and so there was that panic too
of like is this a fight that i'm gonna
have to have down the line to preserve
like
the violence and the blood and the sex
and the swearing and
i don't know so there was a lot of that
but at the end of the day
you know fox supported us and they got
the movies made and
um and and that's that's all i can say
and then
obviously we got into post and then
pandemic happened and then that was like
a whole
whole other thing so at what point did
you
uh did you find out that it was going
from a theatrical release to a streaming
release and did that did that change
anything in post-production
um so we found out kind of i'm trying to
think when it was
it was in the middle of oh my god what
year are we in we're in 2021
it was in the middle of 2020 that
and the thing is is that netflix had
always wanted the movies
they had been pursuing the movies from
like a very early time like before we
had made them
um because they heard about the
experiment of like
movies that were connected and you know
they like to do
cutting-edge stuff so they were
interested then but at that time
we were firmly still at fox um and so
as soon as the merger started happening
they started sniffing around
more i would say and then yeah so it was
like the middle of 2020 that we moved
over to netflix and
like just candidly for me it was a dream
come true um
because i knew that netflix immediately
understood the movies
i knew that they were going to support
the movies how they needed to be
supported as far as like the music that
needed to be in it
and like amazing the effects and things
like that so
nothing really um nothing changed
post-wise like i feel like
it only got better in that regard i know
like you it has to come out you have to
see how it does all of that but
because this has been such a i think i
can safely say unique journey for a film
to take to distribution
when you get picked up by netflix i have
to imagine these were designed as a
potential franchise starter
do they have those conversations with
you when they pick it up
is that something they wait to have
later what is that evolution like
i mean it was it wasn't it was part of
like the initial conversation certainly
with fox like
and because i remember part of my first
pitch that i had with fox was
this is like the potential of fear
street is
basically horror marvel like we're
creating this universe where you can
have
all of these different killers in all of
these different timelines
and time frames and things like that and
to me that was part of the excitement
of the franchise like i was focused on
this right like i just wanted to make
these three movies amazing
but but as just a fan and also with like
my business brain it was like oh [ __ ]
like there's a lot that we can do here
so that was part of that conversation
and certainly it was part of the
conversation when we moved over
to netflix because i think you know
they're also excited about the potential
of
of the universe describing it as heart
horror marvel is making me put into
perspective right now why this has
become like my dream come true
is it just a big old coincidence that so
many people that are involved in
stranger things
were in your movie in front of the
camera and also behind the lens as well
no not at all a coincidence so well
partially
okay so my husband is one of the
creators of stranger things
so he i knew sadie
um from from that show from like being
on set when they were filming
um maya i
had also met and i had this like weird
kind of like
it seems crazy now because it was so
long ago but i knew
i cast her before her character
had premiered on the show so i knew that
like she was kind of like
gonna be like one of like if it went
well she would hit as like a fan
favorite
from from the show and i thought that it
was a perfect kind of like homage to
drew barrymore
and scream and that whole world so um
i felt like that was like some privilege
insider information that i had but then
it like [ __ ] took forever to make the
movies anyway so but anyways
but um and then as far as like my crew
um ross and matt actually stole my
production designer
from honeymoon he's the production
designer on the show
and our set deck on um
your set designer on honeymoon now was a
production designer so i worked with him
scott and then we stole jess jess is our
set deck
and um and shawn our art director on
this movie also works on stranger things
and we had a lot of crew that crossed
over just because it's um
it's atlanta um but i knew a lot of them
and it was great and so
yeah so that's like the weird like
connection to all of that
i love that so much yeah it
comes to the way you shot it and it's
probably a great thing that you knew a
lot of these people before because
how do you prep a crew to do
three different movies back to back in
different time periods with completely
different aesthetics
yeah i mean that is a testament to like
how amazing my art department was like
honestly and then also costume
um camera we spent a lot of time in prep
like discussing how
we would be we would be changing our
style depending on the style of the the
era that we were
you know taking place in but um
our department i think had it our
department and costumes probably had it
the hardest like when we were on the
ground because we were
always chasing that next thing and it's
so schizophrenic it's it's it was great
that we had people that had
series background but it it was totally
different than that
um because we had new we had a new place
we had like a whole new universe that we
had to create with each movie
um so when we would be firmly shooting
94
they're working ahead building the
village for 1666
and you know obviously like constantly
like assaulting me with questions about
it and i'd be like i'm like fully in the
90s
and now you're talking to me about the
17th century and then the same thing
happened like once we did 1666 we had to
start thinking about the 70s and
camp and it was like it was crazy but i
um
i don't know i i joke like it was like
we were in a black hole
where there was like no past and no
future there's just
there's only this moment in front of us
was there any particular reason you went
in that shoot order
um well we we share a lot of cast
between 94 and between 1666
and so it made sen and 78 always was
going to have kind of
its own like cast for the camp part of
it
so it made sense to kind of live in all
of the 90s first to start out the world
like that was our beginning
and 90s is the present of our of our
trilogy
um and then we did we went into 66 so
basically we could
shoot out all of our 94 casts there and
then end on 78 in the new cast
i want to go into some spoilers for 94
so badly but before we do that
can you tell us a little bit about the
casting process because
your main ensemble in 94. that is
like they're not just good i feel like
you only get special ensembles like that
every so often where you become like
very attached to them within minutes of
the movie starting it's very impressive
oh i really appreciate that i agree i
really feel like that too
um and i'm really excited for audiences
to kind of like see them and meet them
um so and it's kind of like
so like okay benji who plays josh
carries like crazy exposition on his
back
and he sells it he sells it
and he's so likable and he's so
believable and
kiana who plays dina and
olivia who plays sam like their
chemistry
and their vibes like it was just really
perfect and then i
that's like not even to begin to talk
about fred who plays simon
and and julia who plays kate who are
like
scene stealers like they were like in
the hands of like lesser actors they
would just be
kind of set dressing you know that are
just like they're around the edges
like to have a snarky comment but i feel
like you grow to love them and
understand them
because the actors are so like
incredible
um so i knew a few of them because i had
done this pilot and i had
um i had like come across them in that
and um and then others i just found like
i had never seen fred before i had never
seen benji before
um ash was new to me ash who plays nick
good he was also new to me
um and i don't know it just kind of all
it all came together in a way that they
just like they felt alive in the read
you know
um and it worked haley hayley's gonna
know this do you know
why i thought fred was just the coolest
because he reminds me of
a younger version of logan miller
and that vibe it just like it it feels
right
he's so good totally i love that vibe
i'm so good um i had a question i wanted
to ask before we move into spoilers as
well
and you kind of touched on it a little
bit but i knowing
the internet i think we're about to have
a very not super fun debate
about the differences between movies and
tv again when this comes out
sure it happened with small acts yes
going to streaming i imagine that'll
happen i think what's cool is that
the way you framed it before was it
accepting that you were working from
structures from both of those mediums
yeah um
was there ever any pushback on that from
people
like no this needs to be approached like
a film it's a cinema experience and how
did you
you know take sort of the best elements
to create your vision
it was it wasn't like it wasn't pushback
per se
but there was a lot of like um
kind of just like weird philosophical
conversations about like how do we do
this
and and and having to kind of like
the writers and i i feel like when we
cracked it we were like
okay we understand what we're doing now
we understand the thing that we have to
do which i you know i said earlier about
like tell this like complete story but
also keep us pushing forward
but then we would constantly have to
remind the producers or the studio and
like bring because they weren't living
in it every day with us
so there was a lot of that of being like
yes we want
cliffhangers but we don't want
cliffhangers that don't resolve we don't
want to not resolve the primary tension
of this movie because
like what are audiences going to feel
like are they you know i didn't want to
feel like
i didn't want audiences to feel like we
were tricking them into a gimmick
i wanted it to feel like it was the
reason we were doing the three movies is
because we had to because of the story
if that makes sense um so yeah so it was
there was there was a lot of like still
like
and also no one knows right so when we
were theatrical it was like
we had this idea like maybe we'll do it
once a month maybe we'll do it
but no one had really like cracked what
that time frame was going to be
um when we got to netflix we actually
did a few different preview structures
to see
like what it would be like if people had
access to all three at once if they had
to wait
this long or this long and we kind of
landed on this
what i think was the perfect kind of
thing which is like one a week
which is so cool because it's still like
an event but
it's also like not so long that you're
like oh god damn it like [ __ ] you spear
street
so wait to backtrack their
preview structures do you do you mean
like uh
like promos that you release that tapped
into it or some sort of testing
experience yeah like testing like
preview testing
we had like two different groups of like
i don't know how many people 500 people
each
and one of them had like access to
all of the movies for a week straight
and they could kind of like
click in and watch when they wanted and
then the other ones
had it like spaced out and and it was
like
the the testing was very similar like
depending there was like a little bit of
wiggle room there was like a little bit
but it was it was very negligible
um which was interesting well i can
confirm that they make for a great binge
watch
really enjoyed that process i'll be
excited
to see how like um to play along with
the week to week two because you're
right it does make it a bit of an
event yeah but i think it's fun also
like
um i hope it's fun i just want to talk
about like
ultimately when the movies come out
there's a lot of like fun things
that you can go back and notice like
once you get to the end
and um so hopefully people finish and
then are like you know what it's
halloween time i'll watch it again or
you know whatever it is and kind of like
have that experience at the very least
i can confirm because i don't think
we're allowed to say anything about the
uh the second two movies i can confirm
that 94 is
highly rewatchable and i'm also like
willing to say that i think it might be
one of my favorite horror movies of 2021
so far um
fully addicted to it actually i can ask
you this
in non-spoiler territory can you talk a
little bit about the
the opening title sequence which is
just incredible like who who did you
work with to craft that
and i don't know maybe are there any are
there any uh
little easter eggs that people should
look out for if uh
if they're watching it for the first
time um well
okay so that title sequence we did kind
of we worked with this amazing
editor named hunter who did a temp title
sequence
for me early on in the process which
kind of used the
the idea of using headlines and then
ultimately
that was just kind of a proof of concept
um that we used
we took basically um a set deck that was
on josh's wall
and and that's what we used for like the
first version of it and then
as we got like further into the process
we hired this amazing company named
elastic
who kind of crafted this thing which
felt like
i i always want like the main thing for
me with fear street was
fun i wanted to be fun like above
everything else
and um and they were able to just kind
of make this like
tonally cool thing which carries us
through
like the 90s part of the sequence is
like so bright and like neon and grey
and kind of like you know is what the
90s parts of the movies are
and then we live in this like great
tomatoey red
for the 70s and then we get into this
like black and white for the 1666.
so there's lots of little there's little
things
in there that in when you get to the end
of everything
and you look back you'll you'll see i
don't want to talk too much
about it the best spoiler though is that
one of the two of the people actually in
the yearbook photos for the 70s are my
parents
i feel like i might have caught some
other familiar names
in the in the chat window along the side
there might be some behind the scenes
people in that mix yeah totally one of
our um
our post producer like the head of
post-production at netflix his name is
there one of my vfx producers
my um my hotmail name
from from the uh the 90s it was was air
and darkness
at hotmail dunk
that's where she comes from and then
another one of my really good friends
from high school that ended up marrying
one of my college roommates actually his
name is one of the names in the chat too
because we like spent so much time on
aol
chatting like i feel like it's where i
got to be a really fast typer
i think we can probably all say that
same thing
it was so nice to tap back into that too
i feel like i completely
forgot what that felt like but this
movie just brought it all back
all right should we do it haley should
we put up the spoiler warning yeah
i think all right all right here it is
we are putting up your one and only
spoiler warning for fear street 1994.
just in case you haven't seen it yet i'm
going to let you know it's going to be
available on netflix july 2nd so you're
you're watching it right now right
you're gonna pause this video go watch
it and then come back and then you can
press play we start right here all right
that's it it's done
i think the first thing i need to ask
you about is the scream homage
in or homages in that opening kill
sequence in particular just to tap back
into what we were talking about earlier
doing something that is you know
as specific as the running shot
that immediately brings back
how do you come to the decision to do
something that is like
from the movie like that um i just
[ __ ] did it and i was
like i don't i was like i was like it's
so
good it's so good and it's so horrifying
and i was like you know what
like it's one thing that i'm lifting
directly
and i feel really happy about it and
really good about it
and so i just did it and um
yeah it was that and then i think the
thing that made the sequence
like ultimately different for me
was that and obviously like whatever
spoiler you already said
um is that in our main like in
that opening mall sequence we unmask him
like we reveal right away
who it is and so it's like oh wait what
movie am i in
so like you feel like you've you've been
in this movie you understand the slasher
movie we're like there's a killer and
he's in a costume and like all of the
thing
but then by unmasking him we were able
to do our own little twist on the
on the thing so and also like just
relatedly this isn't really related to
scream but
i think it's an interesting thing it's
actually related to honeymoon a little i
think i'm just interested in telling
these like messed up
love stories because there's just like
like fear street is a love story like at
its heart it's this love with sam and
dina that like carries us through and
the reason i bring this up now is
because obviously
that was a cool thing for me about um
ryan and heather
in the opening too because they were
like flirty and liked each other and
everything and then it was like oh how
can we destroy
i mean okay so that's a good transition
to something i wanted to ask about which
is you said you know you wanted this to
always be fun and it is
it is also exceptionally brutal at times
and you do like you you set up a nice
thing and then you destroy it
and when i the first time
my heart gets stabbed i was like damn
damn it
i hate that she's about to die but i
didn't get like you know sometimes that
that's dark and it's a brutal feeling
when that character dies how do you
balance that
i don't know you know it was kind of
like the the way
music has a lot to do with it like i
think that like
the music kind of lets you feel like
you're in a certain
place safety wise where it doesn't
and because we were early in the movie
so early in the movie i wanted to make
sure that we were still living in this
kind of like
horror snow globe i think that's like i
don't know if that really makes sense
but that to me that's what it was it was
like we were in this kind of stylized
world of like
she's working late at night at the mall
and there's like these
these um uh nods to fear street in the
books that she's like
you know has at the daltons and
everything like that and and basically
work we basically went back in time
throughout the three
and as we went back from 90s into the
70s and then ultimately to 1666
the horror got more real and more bloody
and more graphic and and um yeah i think
by the time
you get to 1666 it's it's really
it's like it's a very different type of
horror and it's it's not
fun it's it's some of it's fun and it
gets fun
when the 1666 part is kind of like
wrapping up
but it's it's brutal in a different way
so just so you know
i've watched the first two and i forced
myself to stop because i was afraid i
would want to go into the third one
haley's watched all of them so you're
gonna
so yeah haley knows oh my gosh but yeah
you gotta watch that third one and see
yeah i wonder i wonder if some of my
questions here are gonna
speak to what's to come in
those but actually before i even get
there i do want to ask about one
particular kill sequence that
i'm not just saying this like i feel
like it might wind up being one of the
most memorable kill sequences i've
ever seen it's the bread-slicing one
you had done so many things like as we
were just talking about to tee up that
kind of level of brutality but when that
happened
there was an audible react like i cannot
believe you just did that
specifically to that character how do
you come up
with that idea and then please tell me
everything about executing it onset
yeah um well it was kind of like
i don't remember the genesis of it i
remember that we
were very excited about having our
climax of the 90s take place in a
grocery store
part of like the fun of the 90s movie
for me
was being able to kind of take suburbia
and take these places that are really
familiar and yeah and just like
tear them apart and destroy them so i
loved the idea of being able to be in
the grocery store
and um and we you know we kind of like
went through this whole thing of having
the characters have different areas of
the store that they're in they're all
trying to protect sam
and kade ended up in the bakery and
i i don't know i have these like weird
things that i like like i like the idea
of like cake mixing with blood like i
just think it's like a cool like image
and so at one point like we just started
kind of like
riffing on like what could happen in
that in that sequence and then
we we came up with the bread slicer and
it was like it was one of those things
that like when you're reading it
it's horrible but then like you get
closer to like doing it
and you're like wait like this is like
actually crazy and how are we gonna do
this and
there were all of these conversations
with our art department with scott with
sean
with jess being like i don't think a
human head would really do that like
i don't know if you could actually like
and they were like they were like
getting at me they were like i don't
know like this is like a little
unbelievable
and i was like it's [ __ ] cool so
we're gonna do it
and then they bought a bread slicer
and they were like they like wanted to
prove me wrong so they had this idea
that they were gonna throw watermelons
through this bread slicer
and they were convinced that it wouldn't
work and the watermelon just went
right through and if that's like it was
like it was a big cheer moment like we
were at the production office and
everyone just started like clapping and
like cheering and it was amazing and so
then
everyone was sold that this could happen
um and yeah and i think it is i think
it's shocking because it's horrific and
gross and
terrible and i think also because you
love kate
and julia did like such an amazing job
of
of creating this character that you kind
of see
you know change and grow and and we're
late in the movie
and it's late in the movie to kill this
is the thing it's late in the movie to
kill a character
that is such a main character but it's
not late in our trilogy
so like that that was kind of like the
the mindset behind it that we needed
real loss in order to keep our
characters driving forward into the
other movies
i feel like you've achieved that without
having seen the end
i think also that like that whole debate
you were having with your
team like the the almost
unbelievableness
of it wow words but it makes it
hurt slightly less somehow yeah
it is so late and you do grow so
attached to that character but it's a
hell of a like a punch line to the scene
so to speak
yeah yeah oh it's so gross
this might also dig into what's to come
but how did you settle on the assortment
of killers
that we see in this first movie you know
the skull mask etc like was there any
kind of
mixing or matching to find the right
group or i guess did the
next stories necessitate it well it was
kind of like
yeah so in obviously the 70s kind of
provides the
the origin story for nightwing killer
and the thing about like the different
killers is
we wanted to find people that felt
iconic to these other
eras um and so obviously skull mask made
sense in the 90s like there was there
was
no other version of that that i thought
because it i felt like it played homage
to goat face
ghostface but also it was its own thing
you could find the costume in a
halloween store or like a spencer's type
store
um and then with with the nightwing
killer
um he was supposed to kind of evoke that
like classic
like you know killer axe killer in the
woods type thing and
down to his you know buffalo check
jacket and so he definitely needed to be
in the first movie because he was so
much part of like
how we were gonna drive into the second
movie um and then ruby
just like felt cool to me because you
don't
see a lot of like you know female like
slasher killers period so i just thought
that was kind of fun
um but we had like you know we have
other ones which you see at the end of
um
of movie two and it was hard because
it's like i kind of wanted like
everything but we also needed to grow
into like where we were going and and
leave
leave something to like you know kind of
get to but i i don't know so like we had
the milkman and we have what we call the
shame killer later on
um so yeah i don't know how did
for those ones that are you know
obviously
as you spoke to the the two first main
ones really are pulled from the
the styles of the era they're set in
when you go a little further back in
history where did you pull from for
those designs
um i started looking at kind of like
i spent a lot of time on pinterest one
looking at kind of like old masks
so that's where um like the the killer
that has the um
the metal mask that you see just a
little bit in movie two and then you see
a little bit more in movie three
that comes from like a classic i think
like
15th century german shame mask is what
they were called so like
they were like they looked like pigs or
like different animals and if someone
did something horrific they were made to
make wear this mask and i just felt that
that was like
really grotesque and kind of like who
knows what that guy actually did but
it seems awful um and then billy barker
who you also only see a little bit in
the 70s you see more in
the third movie um his kind of like
misshapen face
was i found these like terrible photos
of like depression era kids dressed for
halloween
that were like not fun at all they just
look like it was like
what are these like these are the
scariest masks i've ever seen
and so billy's mask kind of came from
that and then
the milkman just felt like a very kind
of iconic
like 50s um like oh everyone knows like
the milkman that used to come and like
visit the housewives
but i like burned his face and kind of
like made this whole backstory of him
um having been in the war and coming
back and being kind of like
um you know ostracized among his
community and blah blah
and then ruby was just like a fun kind
of like 60s
uh like sex pot type like
girl so yeah all right here's another
here's another question
haley's already warned me that there's
going to be an answer to this but i want
to know
at least what what you think is a
priority to know
right now and it pertains to the rules
of the world
and specifically what your witch
character is
after and and and why
i i guess what can you tease about the
rules in terms of
you know why she possesses a certain
someone to become a killer
why those killers kill certain people
whether or not they have a certain
someone's blood on them
i i know all these questions are
probably good okay so you'll definitely
get all of the answers
in movie three um so i don't really know
exactly how to talk about like the full
situation
there's kind of like a thing happening
okay so the killers only kill
shadysiders unless someone is right in
their path
then they will kill whoever's in their
path to get to the person
who has disturbed sarah fear's grave so
bled on
her grave that's like the main kind of
like
mythology rules of what happens so like
don't disturb sarah fear's bones or
you're [ __ ]
basically um and and we obviously say
like disturb is like specifically like
if you bleed on them but um
but you have to kind of like get to we
we ultimately do answer the question of
like
what the [ __ ] sarah fear like why are
you such a a [ __ ] to shadysiders and
like what happened and
and that's like part of 1666 and then
you kind of start to understand all of
the little nuances of what
of what happened this might be one of my
favorite explainer quotes of all time
[Laughter]
yeah i should have warned that there's
zero chance that i wasn't gonna swear
like
crazy during we're always prepared for
it we do it in our first songs
i always like come in and i'm like you
know what i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
swear
out loud in this and then i just can't
keep my mouth shut
i can relate tremendously poor perry has
to deal with my foul mouth every
i friday like it it automatically comes
with a friday recording but we're
recording on monday so we really have no
excuse today
totally totally
haley do you have any more spoiler
questions that we can tap into
now oh boy um
i you know i have to be so cautious and
we just
just threw my brain to the third movie
um
i will while i uh buy myself some time i
will
back up what you were saying earlier
about how after you've
seen it all you're probably going to
want to go back and re-watch the first
one because that's my plan for tonight
there's like little things that i can
talk about which is like when you
were a little bit like just spoiler-wise
like when you get to
you know movie two shows you kind of the
origin story of the sheriff
of nick goode and what he went through
when he was in
in the 70s and and one cool thing is
that you kind of see
if you look back you see that ash is
kind of limping
in 1994 and you see the origin of that
in the 70s which is cool and was
you know a very good thing for ash to do
and it was incredible and i was like
yeah that's amazing good job actor like
yeah well i love
ash as an actor i was a huge manhattan
fan so when he showed up in the first
movie i literally went ash yes
i always associate those actors in
manhattan with you hayley
because you know i edited that interview
for you yep
uh i i am loudly constantly ringing the
bell for manhattan
over the years that that's how i got to
that's how i became familiar with him
too was through manhattan i was like i
love this so much
i wish there was more of it he's so good
um
he's great he's in succession too he's
been in a lot of things but manhattan
was like
the thing for me that i was like yeah
um i did want to touch on i guess the
the core
queer romance at the heart of this thing
and you sort of
you know referenced earlier that you get
to tell stories that weren't being made
when these 90s slashers were being made
um
and again i find myself not wanting to
say the wrong thing
the approach to it i think is really
lovely and that it frames that story
the same way a straight romance would
have been framed
in the 90s but doesn't feel out of touch
um was that always
the core of your like emotional arc here
and or was it something that came
later as you developed your timeline no
that was always that was always part of
it
and it was interesting like one of the
things about um
you know like i referenced that killers
the killers only kill shady ciders
and part of kind of the core narrative
of the three movies is the idea that
everyone who lives in shady's side feels
outside they feel like other for some
reason they've been told by the world
that like
they're not good enough they're never
gonna get out they're they're not gonna
have a good life
no matter what and we kind of um
you know built the killers as kind of
these like representations of systemic
rot
um and i think that what making the
narrative
about that let us do is that all of our
characters are these
people who have been traditionally told
by society that they're outsiders
and so being able to put a queer love
story at the center of that
like specifically like in horror movies
um
queer i mean it applies to pretty much
anyone but
who's not like a stranger i mean they
die too but
queer women specifically have like a
really bad track record
in in horror um and and so being able to
kind of give them their moment and let
their love kind of push the
stories forward was really important and
you know i would also say that like
it was it was important to like so my
writing partner phil is gay
and we spent a lot of time talking about
how do we make this
we wanted it to just be a love story we
wanted it to just be a teenage love
story that
felt very familiar to anyone who has
not yet known exactly who they are but
know
that they like have a connection with
this other person at the same time
we did we wanted to be true to what it
meant it's it's not
being a queer person in the 90s was not
the same
as being straight like there was a lot
of other things going on so we wanted to
be true to that too and
not just have characters who were fully
out and like fully like
fine with who they were they're still
going through things so it was it was a
balancing act of like being able to like
make the story feel just like universal
and grounded in love which which is
universal and then also to still have
some kind of nuance of like being a gay
teenager in 1994
is different than than what it is now um
so yeah you touched on like when i said
i like that it was framed the way a
straight couple would have been it's
that they're allowed to be
dicks to each other like they're not
this perfected
idealistic tragic couple situation
yeah that's exactly right they it's not
they're not always on the same page sam
is like
[ __ ] unlikable at first like you know
what i mean like she
she's going through a lot and and so
yeah we let them just be kind of like
who they are
but also still like obviously
acknowledging that that their reality is
different than
than what like even like you know kate's
reality is in the movie
um so yeah i'm gonna follow up that
really deep answer with a really
important spoiler question
does is does the vending machine hack
really work
no okay i think it like it felt like
something that really would be a thing
in the 90s
and i spent a lot of time googling it
because i was convinced that there had
to be a way that there was like
secret codes that would work
i never found anything there are like
things
there are like things that you can do if
you're like a manufacturer that you like
put in certain things and it will do it
but like the idea that there's like a
really complicated
like you know a b whatever two nine six
like thing is like
is me just wishing that there were more
secret worlds underneath our own
i might have been googling that after
but yeah you and i had the same google
search then for that
i'm glad we cleared that up for anyone
else who might be googling it now too
all right haley do we want to do our
last two i think we better before we run
out of time
would you like to do the honors first or
would you want me to
whatever you go first all right
i'll go first we always end our
interviews with the same two questions
and the first one is do you have any
pets
i do not currently have any pets i had
two dogs that unfortunately passed away
right around the time i was making
honeymoon so
not right now but they were amazing
their names were fred and hilda they
were whippets they looked like
monsters not dogs and they were
incredible
we've also determined that uh plants
count as pets too right now
yeah i have that
i will uh throw the other one at you
which is
i imagine this is what perry said she
was exactly
the answer to earlier um we always ask
our guests to
offer a recommendation within genre
storing
storytelling whether it's movies or tv
or games or whatever you love just
something that really
captured you lately wow okay that's a
hard one
obviously i when i'm filming
and then when i'm like kind of in post
it's hard for me to like catch up on new
things i'm gonna just talk really
quickly about a lot of different things
so i have been re-watching the great
british bake off
a [ __ ] ton um which is crazy i
finally caught up on small acts and like
really really really really loved lovers
rock like a lot i liked all of it but
like that one i thought was like
beautiful
um but as far as like genre
recommendations
i think this is i actually played this
game
like a few like a few years ago now um
it's called inside so it's by the makers
uh it's an indie game
i played on the playstation uh but i
think you can get it on other platforms
and
it's by the people that made this game
called limbo which was really like very
kind of popular when it came out but
inside was their second game
and it is it's not a long game maybe
like
maybe 20 hours um and it has
the craziest thing that i've ever seen
in video games and maybe in
just general like movies and tv
it has a thing that's like so crazy and
so shocking
and like actually we're not supposed to
talk about the second movie in the third
movie but like
you know this what we call the heart of
darkness i'll just say that the heart of
darkness that exists like under the town
kind of like took a little bit of
inspiration from this insane [ __ ]
thing that happens in this game inside
so
that's my go and and download inside and
play that because it's
incredible it was a very strong pitch
now i'm gonna have to do that awesome
it's so awesome
but now i want to same i want to throw
on a second
like specific to you follow-up since you
were saying you're more
honestly into sci-fi than horror what's
like
what's your latest sci-fi addiction
whether it was last
year or you know like you said you're
busy oh man
i don't you know what it's not actually
a busy thing it stresses me out
it stresses me it's like i watch
something every night but it stresses me
out to watch something that's like
close to the thing that i'm doing so
that's why it's like when i'm doing this
i'm watching great british bake-off or
i'm watching like i
started re-watching party down um like
totally a different world
um i'm trying to think like the la like
um
wait i feel like i just watched
something that i loved that was sci-fi
and now i'm not going to be able to
you know what i always like going into
this i was like i should think about
this because they're probably going to
ask me and now i won't
i don't know it's right there it's on
the tip of my tongue
i don't know i don't know all right fair
enough
i love how i'm like thinking about a
million things right now like i'm gonna
give you a suggestion and that's gonna
be it but no
there's like a million things out there
so much is the thing that like you
i started making a list of everything
that i'm like watching or reading or
or whatever because i was like i can't i
like a good list and then also i just
can't remember
everything because it's so much every
year someone always tells me to start a
letterbox and i start out the new year
like i'm gonna do it this year and keep
track of everything i want and then i
never do it and then i regret it by the
end of the year and it's just a vicious
cycle that repeats
every single year really totally
all right we gotta let you go this was
our
spoiler-filled talk about fear street
1994 so that means you have not watched
1978 which is due out on july 9th and
then there's also
1666 which you can catch on july 16th
i mean congratulations like i i can't
speak to
1666 yet and i'm not supposed to speak
to 1978
so i'll just say that 1994 is fantastic
and i can
not congratulate you enough thank you so
much thank you guys both i'm i'm excited
for you to re-watch and i'm excited for
you to see
the third movie so top priority right
after this
all right i'll talk to you guys soon
thank you thank you so much
wait before you go you've officially
survived the witching hour
you